welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about how the
answer to every conspiracy theory is
apparently
loki from db cooper to mk ultra arcade
games
everything weird about the world is the
doing of this frost giant bastard
i am eric boss with me today is tommy
bechtold hey buddy
eric good to see you i'm so glad to be
back and i'm glad that we finally have
definitive proof that my thurman thomas
autograph that disappeared from my
basement
when i went off to college was not taken
by my sister
and sold on ebay it was simply taken by
the god of mischief
and used for what i can only assume was
an intergalactic prank so
my sister you are forgiven loki you are
on my [ __ ] list now
yes and uh the sinbad genie movie i saw
in the 90s was actually starring loki
yeah i think we're getting to the bottom
of all this yes perfect
great well let's jump into it uh loki is
coming to disney plus in a mere few
months and
um between you and me tommy by far
loki is the uh 2021 marvel title i am
most excited for
and ever since its amazing trailer last
month we
are left wondering all kinds of
questions but uh hi at the top of that
list
is this big question that tommy you're
gonna answer for us this week
what real world historical mysteries
will loki
be the cause of both ones we know about
and what other ones in this trailer
are hiding in plain sight wonderful
question and i feel like i feel
mischievous
discussing them with you maybe i am
possessed by loki
let's talk about what we have confirmed
in the footage d
b cooper baby in the trailer
loki wearing a sharp suit and sunglasses
looking like a prototype for don draper
with neatly combed hair and maybe a
little bit of alcoholism we don't know
and he hijacks the northwest orient
boeing 727
and jumps out with a briefcase full of
cash which is the second best thing to
stuff into a briefcase
the first cocaine
pizza oh cocaine we can cut that out if
you want i don't care
let's talk about the actual db cooper
mystery slash conspiracy
dan cooper which was changed to dp
cooper through
i think just kind of a mistake in in the
telephone game people reporting it
the name on the manifest was actually
dan cooper it's the pseudonym of an
unidentified man who hijacked a boeing
727
in the united states airspace between
portland and seattle so probably pretty
rainy and good coffee
on the afternoon of november 24th 1970
fun
1971 the man purchased his airline
ticket using the alias dan cooper
but because of news miscommunication as
i said uh he became known in popular
lore as
db cooper it's estimated he extorted 200
000 in ransom which would be about 1.26
mil
today in 2021 and then he parachuted to
an uncertain
fate like an army man that i threw off
the bay bridge
he is somewhere in lake ontario he's not
he's somewhere in a pacific lake despite
an extensive manhunt
and protracted fbi investigation the
perpetrator has never been located or
identified
it remains the only unsolved case of air
piracy
in commercial aviation history baby i'm
so excited that loki
is uh linking to db cooper we were so
caught off guard when we saw that in the
trailer and it it's mind-blowing
honestly
i remember watching mad men and everyone
thought the final twist of the final
season of mad men was that don draper
was gonna be db cooper
because they kinda the timeline's kinda
linked up a little bit
yeah yeah some people you know db cooper
was like kind of described as a handsome
gentleman with a nice suit you know but
instead we got the coke commercial so
yeah yeah uh db cooper is just such a
fascinating piece of uh american
mythology because like
before 9 11 airplane hijacking was a bit
sexier and uh and people love this idea
of a guy who could hijack an airplane
and you know they never found his body
he's probably dead you know
uh but like that he could kind of get
away with it yeah
he could parachute out it's just so
crazy and fictitious
but it happened beyond belief as they
say on the old jonathan frake show
have you ever had the desire to write
your initials in wet cement
no it is like truly it seems like how
could this be
how like we're so good at finding lost
stuff how could this
how could this man have just vanished
why do we think loki
is uh taking the place of db cooper are
they saying that loki was
always db cooper or is he like quantum
leaping well no one knows who db cooper
is
right it's a pseudonym so i think maybe
the
explanation would be that loki simply
used the pseudonym db cooper
to get the cash that he needed for
something
as means or maybe he was bored i think
that the name
db cooper is simply just another weapon
in the loki utility belt
is my guess yeah it's so weird i mean he
left some of that cash behind when he
got bifrosted out of there
my theory is that like loki history is
set in stone
but loki is going back to these things
and like quantum leaping
into them just to like run amok you know
his goal is to burn down the timeline so
he's going to these like
lapses in the timeline to just try to
further screw with stuff
and meddle with things and make it even
worse what's another one this one is a
bit harder to spot
this polybius game that shows yes
in president loki's trashy hangout
amongst the hoarded odds and ends is a
polybius arcade game
let's talk about the history of the
polybius game this is kind of an urban
legend of an unheard of new arcade game
just randomly appearing
in several suburbs of portland oregon
all right what's going on with portland
here are you picking up uh
a connection portland oregon here it's a
weird
northwest connection here yeah northwest
connection which is uh the second best
rap group next to west side connection
they uh
they did it best but northwest
connection had some
really great raps about lumber uh okay
so anyway
and so this all happened in 1981 it was
something of a rarity that people talked
about at the time
the game is described as uh as being so
popular that people
instantly got addicted to it uh with
lines forming around the machines often
resulting in physical fights over who
would play next
the legend also describes the machines
were visited by men in black who
collected unknown data from the machines
allegedly testing responses
to the game's psychoactive effects so
players actually suffered a series of
unpleasant side effects including
amnesia insomnia
night terrors and uh hallucinations so
not exactly
turtles in time
[Music]
approximately one month after its
supposed release in 1981 polybius is
said to have disappeared
without a trace the company named in
most accounts of the game is
cena schlossian the word is described by
writer brian dunning as not quite
idiomatic german meaning
sense delete or sensory deprivation the
thing is is like
the game didn't exist or
did it like this is this is what i
consider to be a fun conspiracy theory
yes because like
whether or not this game existed i want
to live in a world where this game did
exist
and it's like the concept of urban
legends
it's almost a community thing where like
one community bands together to swear
something is true you know a lot west
monster things like that where it's like
okay so the these people in portland
probably
even if it wasn't real they'll never
admit it you know like this is their
urban legend that they perpetuate so
it's like
the the whole fun of a nice urban legend
that has like a has a location is that
those people will swear by its accuracy
they'll swear that it actually happened
you know ufos
things like that sounds like a bunch of
mumbo jumbo trash to me
and this is uh it's similar enough to
things that have happened like you know
mk ultra you know that happened uh the
government
trying to spy on us yeah has been true
that was uh later popularized
with you know after the patriot act went
out and with edward snowden's release
whistleblowing um but like it's true
enough
yeah it's true enough it's kind of like
a condensation of other
real uh verified conspiracy theories
that
uh you know i kind of want to live in
this world yeah
or i don't know if i want the government
to be spying on us but like
if it's just through an arcade game and
they're just like testing to see and it
doesn't really screw up our life in
other ways
ah that's harmless i'll allow some light
data collecting on me as long as i get
really cool technology
as long as i can like control my tv and
appliances with
basically glorified power gloves they
can spy on me a little bit through my
video games by
conceding that on camera in this video
you have given them permission
just like posting on facebook it's like
the opposite of that like
if you say you're oh god basically
my photos are my privacy if facebook
does not own my photos or my posts
my brilliance that has been written on
facebook statuses is mine and mine alone
[Laughter]
you and i know some fun uh brilliance
that's been written in facebook oh
good lord but it's so inside inside
inside the baseball that
even most friends of ours wouldn't know
what we were talking about yes
and i'll say this zuckerberg if you're
listening you can have my posts you
jackass
all right moving on there was another
one that i found
after the where i found this like roman
numerals uh
translated to 79 and then later on the
fact that people were like you realized
that's when
pompeii was destroyed right now holy
[ __ ] so tell us about this one pompeii
vacation goals
yes uh pompeii where was a roman city
that was destroyed by the eruption of
mount vesuvius in
79 a.d it's a location of the first
discovered seder square in a brief shot
loki dances with a woman in ancient
ropes and on the wall besides them
are the roman numerals lxxix or 79
in 79 a.d as you said it before eric the
ancient city roman city pompei was
destroyed
as i said leaving behind many mysterious
runes including the seder square which
inspired christopher nolan's tenant
which inspired me to watch that movie
with my mom which inspired me to spend
six hours of my life trying to explain
that movie that i didn't understand to
my mom
who didn't understand even more yikes we
waited for that
people risked their lives for that what
was that movie about
why why was it worse than a rubik's cube
i would have rather tried to solve a
rubik's cube for two hours and 40
minutes
then try and figure out whether or not
robert pattinson was that lady's son
from the future which is what i thought
and would have tied it up at a robert
zemeckis bow for me but instead no he's
just
some guy oh i think he is the son i mean
we did a whole video about this and
tommy i i spent like a couple days
working on that with
our editor john trying to piece together
what they would look like i didn't watch
it for a couple months and then i was
like
wait what happened to tennant i had to
watch my own video
to try to remember what happened in that
movie and i was confused
by the video that i wrote well i
don't remember let me tell you and this
is this is a testament to our friendship
the first thing i thought as i concluded
the movie yesterday was
i need to watch eric's videos on this
because it's the only way i'm going to
understand what i just watched
and then i can repeat to my mother so i
will watch your content
and i will explain to my mom in a
one-hour lecture
what the hell we watched and then we
will forget it ever happen and just
stick to interstellar where they spoon
feed us the mcconaughey
um yeah um i would love
if uh loki just with one episode is able
to make more
sense of the seder square that
lieutenant did like how
insane would that be crazy parallel
thinking for loki a show that was being
developed during
2018-2019 uh to deal with like
a pompeii in the seder square when
obviously they would have no idea
what tenet was going to be about that
you know they tenant kept its plot
tightly under wraps until it came out
so i really really hope that loki makes
some sense out of that whole mystery but
was there anything else that was
on camera or something that we've seen
in footage that might be
a clue to what loki's gonna revisit eric
i believe you
you gave your best uh you served your
best sherlock holmes with a little
sleuthing to conclude we may have some
zodiac connections correct
yeah you know what there might be some
zodiac and loki yeah let's talk about it
in kevin feige's initial pitch of the
loki series in 2019
the concept art showed loki in an urban
70s setting with a jaws movie title
on a theater marquee jaws released in
the summer of 1975 about a year after
the final confirmed zodiac letter was
sent now let's do a little history
on the zodiac killer the zodiac killer
is ted cruz
no yeah he's 39
the zodiac killer is the name of an
american serial killer who operated in
northern california
just south of oregon ironically at least
in the late 1960s into the early 1970s
the unidentified killer originated
uh the name in a series of taunting
letters and cards sent to the san
francisco bay area press
these letters included four cryptograms
or ciphers so we've got a lot of like
puzzles and clues and things like that
so far showing up in this which uh you
know loki's an intellectual so i'm not
i'm not surprised to see that yeah
the only reason why i'd be um hesitant
to see if the zodiac killer will show up
in loki is that it's so freaking dark
yeah you know people were murdered
people lost their lives
real life murders yeah so like yeah some
of the best conspiracy theories and
mysteries in in history are ones about
like
people innocent people getting
slaughtered i don't know if loki's gonna
like make some jokey sci-fi
yeah tomfoolery out of that that's a
little that's a little too clip that's
that i think you saved that for the
hunters on amazon
yeah or one of those other like really
super i mean i know these are comic book
movies but like i feel like like a
tarantino
might take on the zodiac killer with
like a with a more rye
take a look at it now as we move on to
like some of the
other maybe possibilities things that we
don't have evidence from
loki yet but things that like based off
of d.b cooper and politius they might
address uh just to kind of like cross
these off the list
we probably won't see any mysteries over
the jfk assassination
uh or jack the ripper just because do
you really
think you're gonna see loki on the
grassy knoll as
you know a jackie oh is sobbing and
covered in her husband's blood
no you're not gonna see that on disney
plus folks nothing bad
ever happens to the kennedys and jack
the ripper even though it's been kind of
this mythologized
thing if you look in history jack the
ripper women were being
horribly massacred around london and he
wrote these creepy ass letters
to scotland yard it's yeah it's uh not a
fun thing to revisit you know a
conspiracy theory about jack the ripper
i just simply have to add in to stay on
brand is that he's buried in rochester
new york
whoa one of the alleged uh leads on who
jack the ripper is is a guy from england
who came over to america and moved to
rochester uh flower city everybody rise
up 585 we got jackie
ribs a lot of people think jack the
ripper that's why he's never caught as
he fled to america
and you know this was the turn of the
century victorian era they didn't keep
track of everyone
right who who made it out he hates to
leave america
i should hate to go there that could be
where he ended up
yeah we don't know but what are some
other possible conspiracy theories
yeah we've got bigfoot loch ness monster
is loki just dressed up in a a big furry
costume
i mean in that weird way the only way i
could see that
is if it's a montage if they bang this
out montage style sounds like a
franchise
he is the originator of urban legends
and and conspiracies in america
he has every conspiracy theory like he's
just simply responsible for all of it so
you get amelia earhart you get jimmy
hoffa you know like he's just doing
all of those unsolved disappearances and
whatever yeah
amelia earhart is an interesting one to
consider because she just kind of went
missing her plane never
made it back and i think maybe it went
down
somewhere in the pacific but like yeah
is uh
is sofia di martino's character like a
version of amelia earhart it was just
displaced from history and
now that's who she is because she is she
was kind of like a hero
you know we have museums and statues in
her honor you don't want to do anything
that would like
tarnish her legacy i'm not one to shy
away from danger
what about the uh roanoke lost colony
i think there was just some information
that came out about roanoke right that
they were able to do some research and
find
where those settlers went oh no i'm not
caught up on roanoke eric do we have do
we have a
late breaking news on roanoke as of this
year in november 2020 the
archaeologists just came up with some
details about roanoke how
you know there's a whole mystery of
croatone was uh carved in the tree
uh but they were able to find other
things based off of
maps and pottery shards and other
archaeological dig sites
that link it to the roanoke colony so it
really just sounds like the settlers
just moved on to another area uh
and and built a new colony there they
wanted something with a better view
we should take roano colony and push it
somewhere else maybe loki could tie into
that whole thing
because i think a lot of these will just
be kind of like one-off jokes i think so
too
will there be an entire episode about
each of these things maybe not
however uh i think there are some
conspiracy theories about
extraterrestrials there
are things from outer space there's a
whole thing about the big wow
signal you know where it was kind of
like what contact ended up being based
on
it was like they heard this crazy signal
from outer space and it happened only
once and never again
yeah maybe that could be like uh loki's
some kind of battle
in earth's orbit and it just disappears
oh yeah
i think the most likely one tommy might
be that uh crazy solid wafer
spaceman photo remember that one where
if a guy took a picture a firefighter
took a picture of his daughter
and there's this crazy looking like
spaceman standing by her and he's like
yeah yeah
there was no guy there and a lot of
people are trying to debunk it saying
that like
no the guy's just full of [ __ ] that it
was his wife who's just turned a certain
way
i would love if like loki had to wear
some hazmat suit and then he just
happened to show up in this guy's photo
and then
uh space stoned out of there right
afterwards oh my god that's really funny
that would be awesome let us know in the
comments below what other
real world mysteries and conspiracy
theories you want to see the loki series
tie into i think this is a fascinating
opportunity to have loki quantum leap
throughout history and answer some of
these uh
long running mysteries that we've never
had answers to the answer is loki
bastard let's move on to some people who
helped us make this episode
yeah let's talk about it let's talk
about something near and dear to my
heart honey
oh my honey oh my darling these days
online shopping is about the only
shopping we do
not me i go to the digital underground
where i buy dark [ __ ] on the dark web
just kidding honey we'll start that over
these days online shopping is about the
only shopping we do that's where today's
sponsor honey comes in
it's the free browser extension that
scours the internet for promo codes and
automatically tests them
when you're checking out no thanks honey
my
shopping is a secret just kidding i love
bargains honey is basically your online
shopping
best friend as opposed to my real best
friend zach hall
who only takes from me money my wife
my cars my kids on easter
suck it zack anyway get honey on your
computer for free
and two easy clicks then when you're
checking out on one of its over 30 000
supported sites
honey just pops up and all you have to
do is click apply coupons it's like a
savings leprechaun it pops up when you
most need it and if you catch it it owes
you a wish
wait a few seconds as honey searches for
the coupons for that site
if honey finds working codes it'll apply
the best one to your cart
off-screen producer zach not zac hall
zach huddleston
the good zack used honey recently to
save five bucks on some flowers
he was buying online for his mom be like
zach
and save money on some marigolds for
mama unless your mom is allergic to
flowers like mine is
then use honey to get her allergy
medicine honey has found it's over 17
million members over two billion dollars
in savings that's billion
with a b baby honey supports all kinds
of retailers
from tech and gaming sites to fashion
brands
and even food delivery maybe you could
save on honey by using honey
i don't know would the world collapse on
itself was that what tennant was about
it's simple if you have a computer honey
should be on it
not real honey that would break the
computer honey the browser extension
it's free and it works with whatever
browser you use you can get honey for
free today at joinhoney.com
big question that's join honey dot com
slash big questions so they know we sent
you tell them
large marge sent you thanks honey for
supporting today's episode
did you know large march was 37 when she
died according to her birth of death
date and pee-wee's big adventure oh
that's sad that they decided to make
that her history
yeah she's 37 she looked 80. anyway
let's talk about gabby
we're all looking for ways to save money
right yes
yes gabby customers save an extra 961
dollar yas
961 dollars a year per year on average
on car
and home insurance do they have bear
insurance because i'm getting attacked
in the woods
daily by these grizzlies gabby takes the
pain out of shopping for insurance
by giving you an apples to apples
comparison of your current coverage
with 40 of the top insurance providers
like progressive
nationwide and travelers insurance you
down with pnt
yeah you know me that's progressive
nationwide
and travelers the big three as i call
them link your current insurance account
and in just minutes you'll be able to
see quotes from that exact same coverage
you currently have that's what i did
gabby was incredibly fast and easy to
use
i'd been with my old insurance company
for over five years and gabby helped me
realize i was overpaying i don't even
own a car
legally i can't drive and yet i was
giving my money away every month i
logged in
with my current insurance provider it
showed me over a dozen quotes and i was
able to save
a bunch of money not bad i like that
still can't drive a car but maybe i'll
get a tank and take my vengeance out
[Laughter]
with 961 dollars per year on average
that gabby customer save you could buy a
full wardrobe of new rockstars merch
burrito bowls for days
and a new fullback tattoo of babufrik
and they'll never sell your info so no
that's not even something babufrik said
that wasn't
[Music]
buddy frick is bobo's brother uh he's
got a problem
okay yeah okay where was i they'll let
you know so you can relax knowing you
have the best rate out there and they'll
never sell your info so no annoying spam
or robo calls
from them but you still can have five
fabulous nights in vegas
if you sign up at tommytrips.com so
don't skimp on that
what that's my robocalling service so
you're probably overpaying on car
and home insurance see how much gabby
can save you
it's totally free to check and there's
no obligation go to gabby.com
big question that's g-a-b-i dot com
slash big question gabby.com
slash big question baby
all right so now we are going to move on
to some bite-sized questions that
i'm gonna answer uh so what do we got
this week tommy all right
we've got a little bit of a connection
montoya23 on twitter via justin r brown
on facebook asked in civil war who
texted cap to tell him peggy carter had
died
hmm you know what this is an interesting
question i i
i kind of wondered this
[Music]
i just kind of assumed it was one person
but you know so just to remind people
in civil war cap was notified that uh
peggy carter had died while he was with
sam and natasha and other people in uh
the avengers compound so it could not
have been one of them
uh and it probably would not have been
bucky because you know bucky was on the
run in that movie cap hadn't caught up
with him yet
hardcore parkour
fire car if you look at the phone number
on that phone it is four four
zero two zero seven nine four six zero
seven
two two and you know we should start off
by saying
cap did not save that number in his
phone under any specific contact name
so tommy either cat doesn't know how to
work phones that good
which is very possible because the guy
is still figuring out what star wars is
i'll put it on the list
or or is it a contact that he didn't
think it necessary to list
contact information for now when you
just put in that number in google
a lot of marvel fan sites will just
credit it to sharon carter they assume
sharon carter
was the one who texted him because kat
knew sharon gardner from winter soldier
but if you remember in that scene it's
of war cap was genuinely surprised
to see sharon carter step up to the
pulpit to deliver the eulogy he must
have not known that sharon and peggy
were related had he
kept sharon as a kind of peggy related
contact in his phone he would have known
that they were related
so by that logic that number was
probably not sharon carter
but you know back in winter soldier cap
was meeting with old peggy
in her hospital bed uh in her home
so he probably was in touch with
whatever shield contacts or
caretakers were looking after peggy so
maybe
the person who texted him was just one
of those caretakers that text
was brisk as she's gone
period in her sleep she's
a show some bedside manner this is her
longtime friend she's
gone in her sleep it's kind of like when
uh kingsley and harry potter crash the
weasley decor
wedding with the scariest voicemail of
all time
the ministry has fallen minister of
magic
is dead by the way congratulations on
your wedding i brought you a toaster but
it'll show up later
after everyone's dead
i'm gonna say based off of the fact that
it's all business so the text might have
just come from nick fury
or maria hill that sounds like a text
they would have sent right
though another but here tommy wouldn't
you say their phone numbers would have
shown up as encrypted
on uh cap's phone maria hill and
nick fury we're talking about so here's
a answer that the
true fans want was this mystery texture
old
cap oh well it depends
on how marvel chooses to interpret the
timeline logic of old cap and adventures
end game now the directors of course say
old cap lived his life in an alternate
branch history
but the screenwriters for whatever
reason still insist that old cap was
just in the background of the main mcu
history the whole time
so if the screenwriters are right i
guess old cap could have been present at
peggy carter's funeral
but he's not a pallbearer as has been
theorized that is a different guy if you
look at the set photos or just some
random
dude but theoretically steve could have
had a friendship with
his with this just random old man who
looked a lot like him
who he later finds out is the future
version of himself that old man saying
uh by the way our wife is dead she
is gone in her sleep
that might be why cap never moves on
after the snap
he's like look i had this old friend uh
and
he based off of this i know some time
travel bs
is in my destiny oh you gotta be
[ __ ] me
so that when in game when scott lang
shows up babbling about time travel
steve's like aha yep this is it this is
how i'm gonna turn into my old self
and this is proof that i will never ever
ever learn
proper cell phone etiquette i love going
down that rabbit hole but
you know that directly contradicts the
movie's own branch timeline
time travel rules so to answer your
question fellas
that mystery texter was probably nick
fury or maria hill
or uh one of those caretakers or shield
contacts who's looking after peggy
carter but was not
was not sharon carter cold-blooded
cold-blooded
all right hit me with that next one baby
all right civilian via the discord asks
where did general grievous's many
lightsabers come from
ah now this is a difficult one to answer
uh general grievous from revenge of the
sith the separatist
general uh he prided himself in jedi
hunting
and sabre clayton during the clone wars
uh we see him lift his cloak he's got
about four of them there and we know he
has four from when he fights obi-wan
uh he has way more in his collection
though
this guy's got like a whole box of these
things
jangly ones it's a whole shoe box full
of mud dangly ones
i think he said dangly not jingly i'm an
idiot
the reason this is hard to answer is
because a lot of the stories that hint
at the way grievous got those sabers
are not really considered canon you know
kind of like that 2003 animated clone
wars
uh deleted scenes are only debatably
canon
like for example it was previously
thought that he got his first lightsaber
from jedi master sifo diaz you remember
him he's the one
who broke away from the jedi and uh
started the whole clone army with the
camino ends and there is a whole
backstory involving him and dooku
and uh and grievous but this idea of
grievous gaming's first lightsaber from
cypherds was later retconned in the
clone wars series
scifo diaz's lightsaber was found
elsewhere now we can say that grievous
got one of his blue sabers from
the jedi pablo jill from floating debris
after an intense duel
left that jedi wounded and then uh it
was all during a very intense duel on a
collapsing satellite
over duro uh grievous got one of his
green sabers from
eth cough who was captured by grievous
on salukami's system
during the clone wars but was able to
get away not with the saber though
uh grievous got another green one from
roran karab when he
uh stormed the capital on coruscant to
capture chancellor palpatine
during the battle of coruscant now some
people say grievous might have gotten
another blue one from the jedi master
shakti
that was the jedi who was sent to try to
rescue chancellor kind of his last line
of defense
but she was killed however tommy that
was in a revenge that says deleted scene
now obi-wan and anakin did talk about
shakti
trying to go rescue the chancellor in
the clone wars season 7 a scene that was
canon
what about the chancellor the shark tea
has been sent to protect him but master
windu has lost contact with her
it's just hard to know if grievous
killing her and getting her lightsaber
is canon so i don't know if it really
counts either way
now there was another saber that
grievous got from master
crook during the battle of hypori though
that was also in the 2003 clone wars
which is not considered
canon and it was believed that uh
grievous got one's from full mudama
rothdel masona and [ __ ] ultria grievous
briefly held nadar vebbs lightsaber
until
it was recovered by kit fisto uh and
some people say he held the lightsaber
of darth zannah uh sith lord from the
time of
being jury is still out on which of
these stories will be real some people
are hoping that bane will show up in the
acolyte
uh and we might get some pieces of that
history but i think
overall don't get too precious over
these four lightsabers being like
what is the story behind these just know
that this guy's got
a whole freaking room of these things
and he's like the crazy scary vietnam
vets
who carry uh necklaces of severed ears
do you have any idea what it's like out
there
do you is that offensive tommy do we
have to cut that
i don't think so i think it's uh
terrifying
well there is your answer that is how uh
just know that he's
killed and captured a lot of jedi yeah
every lightsaber is one that he got from
a jedi he killed he's just
disarmed a lot of people he's a very
freaky boy
[Music]
with a bad cough and we barely got to
know him in revenge of the sith
god bless clone wars for showing us more
of general grievous
yeah that's pretty cool uh and he
doesn't care
where he gets his lightsabers he doesn't
get his diamond certification
is this a blood no thank you yes please
he's he's got to collect them all gotta
catch em all yeah
all right uh we have time tommy for one
more
box scraps question
uh that we're gonna answer this one
comes from actually sauceless our friend
on discord who asks
if you were to believe in one conspiracy
what would it be just one can't we have
the most
yeah just one i uh try not to be
uh into conspiracy theories i try and
laugh at them
and try and you know dismiss them but
in reality in my heart of hearts i think
if any conspiracy theories are to be
proven true any famous ones
it's gonna be something so ridiculous so
that's why
i think it is the old paul mccartney
got in a awful car wreck on a rainy
night
in liverpool way back when in the 60s
and died in a car accident
and was replaced by an american double
who had similar facial features but then
was operated on
uh to look exactly like paul mccartney
and then learn to sing
uh but was never as good there's a whole
documentary on netflix which is
absolutely insane and proof that
anything can go on netflix
that proposes that one of the big
reasons that all of the beatles actually
hated the new paul mccartney because one
he took the place of their friend but
also that he was such a terrible
musician that they had to work extra
hard
to make the music sound authentically
beatles and in that documentary
they also proposed that there was a girl
in the car accident who got
injured who also had radical uh plastic
surgery
and then became heather mills who would
go on to
marry and royally screw over paul
mccartney
now that would make heather bills who
was like 30 years younger than paul
mccartney actually the same age as him
so
i'm not quite sure how that documentary
felt like adding that detail in was
going to make it more plausible
but i like that they took a big swing so
for me
you play the record backwards it says
paul is dead you play my head backwards
it says paul is dead
as well what about you eric what's up
what's a uh what's a conspiracy theory
you think might be real
i love all the different like uh rock
band and pop band uh conspiracy theories
the paul is dead one's fun
i've just learned about the the larry
uh the harry styles louis one direction
uh relationship because i think it's so
pure even though all conspiracy theories
lead to people
uh harassing random people on twitter
and it sucks
uh i love that one where was
a roller coaster of love it has a
screaming in the background and it's
from
a woman who they use for the cover cover
whose legs got
adhesively stuck to a bunch of honey
they had
and then that her skin was being ripped
off as they tried to remove her yes
yeah i love that one pop culture
conspiracy theories are harmless ones
for the most part unless they're real
and then awful right but
my favorite conspiracy theory if i had
one to choose to be true
fake melania oh i can't get enough of it
it's so funny to me
that like because it's bizarre yes but
man i have seen a couple of these uh
side-by-side pictures and being like
this is not the same person
and just being like what is that she's
like six inches shorter
yeah i mean look tommy there are plenty
of side by side pictures of me
uh taking like days apart where i look
like
and one and the other and it's just
it's me you know it's all me but there
are clones of me
uh at the end of the day yes but i have
one in my room so this idea that there
might be a fake melania
it's just so funny to me it's probably
not true i just lied it's so joyful
but it's still this theory exists and
now we can kind of laugh at it
yeah i think until it's proven
[Laughter]
i don't know i don't know if i can eric
because according to the comments of our
youtube videos i
put uh subliminal right wing messages in
our videos
we know he's one of us come to parlor
uncle tommy come
on you know what follow me to the
conversation on parlor where free speech
is always
encouraged the president is a lizard
so much free speech that the app
glitches and falls apart
but it's free well that is it for this
controversial episode of the big
question
thank you tommy for joining this episode
what a pleasure you can follow tommy at
tommy bechtel follow me at ea boss
follow new rockstar send us your big
questions using the hashtag
bigquestion uh subscribe to the podcast
feed
and if you don't mind give us a nice
reading review there and subscribe to
rockstars here on youtube hit that
notification bell
see you next week i can't wait uh for
loki to prove us wrong
on most of what we said
oh yes
[Music]
you